si nous devions observer une forme de
continuité dans l'aggravation de la
situation
c'est à dire dans les incidences ne
proposons pas de mettre en oeuvre le
confinement à paris d'abord parce que
cette décision relèvera de l'exécutif
national mais nous pensons que la
politique des demi mesures
avec des résultats très contestable et à
une forme de fin de cycle et donc nous
souhaitons mettre en débat
quelques options fondamentales et nous
appelons l'exécutif national allait
trancher soit nous sommes en capacité de
continuer cette stratégie dû vivre avec
et il est il a incontestablement notre
préférence qui consiste à dire on crée
des mesures de contrainte
on assume un haut niveau de circulation
du virus sans mettre en danger les taux
d'occupation des pato réanimation en
particulier et auquel cas des
ajustements sont nécessaires mais face à
l'aggravation de la situation sanitaire
nous disons que la politique des
demi-mesures qui consiste à compléter
par séquences en rajoutant des
difficultés aux difficultés sans
résultats sanitaires probant pose la
question ou pas de l'arbitrage de la
part de l'exécutif national sur un
confinement plus dur évidemment
le cette hypothèse ne peut pas concerner
que paris n'en est pas question
je redis que ce n'est pas une demande de
notre part il n'a jamais été une demande
de notre part mais simplement une
hypothèse que nous souhaitons mettre sur
la table notamment parce que je le redis
nous enchaînons depuis des mois et des
mois des vies sous contrainte
extrêmement forte sur le plan économique
sur le plan moral aussi
et c'est évidemment extrêmement
important sur le sujet de
l'acceptabilité des mesures qui sont
proposés aux français et ne voudrions
pas nous retrouver dans la situation et
j'insiste sur ce point ou face à la
dégradation de la situation sanitaire
nous prendrions ce que nous qualifions
de demi mesures supplémentaires de type
confinement le week-end et c'est comme
ça a été fait à d'autres endroits ne
faisons que retardée si la situation
sanitaire se dégradent est une forme
d'inéluctabilité dont beaucoup de
conseils scientifiques nous témoignent
d'un confinement plus dur de façon à
ensuite pouvoir se projeter dans des
perspectives et c'est aussi sur cela que
nous voulons insister